Hey,
what's going on and spill?
Burn.
It's time for the Monday morning.
Podcasts from March 14th,
2016 how are you doing?
How's it going?
How are you all?
Wow.
You look great.
Did you lose,
is that a new blouse?
What did she tell you?
Did something different?
Um,
ah,
is there anything worse than watching somebody do that?
You know,
coming up and they,
they take the two women meet,
right?
And they grab each other by both hands.
Right?
And then they look at you and they fucking hold the hands out.
I think I've talked about this before.
Look at you.
What are you doing?
You know,
secretly hated the woman cause she looks better.
I can't you be like guys,
we just look each other in the ag.
I said Pussy,
I don't,
I'm talking about,
oh Billy fucking cuisine over here.
I want to try to make Gnocchi this week or no?
Yeah,
where the fuck you supposed to pronounce it?
Um,
it doesn't seem too fucking hard.
Right?
So anyways,
we got these old pants,
right?
Like everything in my life.
It's fucking old,
right?
I'm old and everything I own is old,
cause I bought it when I was young.
Um,
so I guess the Teflon or whatever the nose shit.
Well you want to have,
it was ted scraped off over the years and was flaking up and somebody told my
lady that it was getting in our foods.
So now of course all that God,
we've got to get rid of,
you know,
or eating Teflon fucking omelettes.
Evidently.
I don't know.
I didn't taste it.
My fucking omics bomblets or rather the delicious.
I didn't feel any Lino crunchy.
Like,
wait a minute.
What was that?
What does that,
what does that onions or was that part of the frying pan?
I can't tell.
It's such a similar taste.
Eggs and parts of the frying pan,
you know,
I don't know.
I figured,
you know,
with the amount of booze and I do whatever that,
that,
you know,
Teflon that went to my system got eaten up by the fucking my liquid diet.
Right.
But whatever.
So now we gotta go get a fucking frying pan.
So I go,
all right.
You know,
we,
we have one nice one and then we had like three shit ones.
So the three shit once,
I guess we're giving us cancer because someone who isn't a doctor saw,
saw the pants and told us that that was what was,
what was happening.
So we threw those outs and all that.
I'm sure those are going to be fucking hitting some octopus on the fucking head
when they dump it into the ocean soon and up to now I'm going to go buy some
work,
right?
I already had what I needed and I throw it out tonight.
I got to go buy some more classic fucking capitalism.
It's how it works.
It's how we keep it going.
That's how we keep the plates spinning.
You go out,
you buy what you need and then when you have it,
you throw it out and then your rebuy it and the second people stopped doing
that.
This whole country goes down the shitter.
That's it.
That's how simple it is.
All these fucking stupid terrorists over there,
you know who think they've got to come over here and bomb us?
All they gotta do is just,
just start sending leaflets over here,
telling us not to buy stuff.
Hey wait,
you already own that?
You don't need to buy that.
Keep the money.
Treat yourself.
Put your feet up.
Don't go to the mall.
Relax.
Just send,
you know,
propaganda like we used to in the,
in the wars,
right.
We drop and drop little leaflets.
You know,
I would love to read one of those.
Everything that ain't fucking pictures of those wartime leaflets to try to get
people like,
I don't understand how the fuck are you going to do that?
Like,
I don't think I could ever fly over Yankee stadium with leaflets telling people
to become red sox fan.
So like,
how do you dern a fucking war when the country that's bombing your country's
going to send you a leaflet.
What the fuck does it say on it?
Yeah.
Hey,
sorry about,
are most of your relatives a anyways,
you want to come over to our side?
We could get you AMC in which they're fucking smoky.
Um,
alright.
Let's see.
World War,
two leaflets.
Leaflet.
Propaganda.
All right.
Let's read a couple of these.
Let me see if this would make you fucking switch sides.
Go from Red Sox to the Yankees are fucking Dodgers to giants are fucking
avalanche to the fucking red wings or a Michigander
hi.
You get,
um,
all right.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Look at this one.
Why are you German?
Still fighting?
Not that that's no way to get the reader.
The question is extremely difficult to answer.
Did they understand that these people spoke,
spoke German?
You're going to write it.
This is almost over my head and I speak the fucking language.
Uh,
why are you German still fighting on via your Jeremy's still fighting's a
funeral.
Blow his fucking brains out next to his six of a chip.
Then,
uh,
the question is extremely difficult to answer.
In fact,
there is no reasonable answer to it at all.
You go on fighting,
although you cannot,
I should believe fucking click on the page here so I can read this a little
bigger.
Oh,
and then it always disappears.
Doesn't it always disappear?
You just click on it.
Where did it go?
Okay,
there we go.
All right?
You go on fighting,
although you cannot
help but realize that Germany is losing the war.
Wow.
Jesus.
This would make me want to be you have fuck these fucking assholes.
Uh,
you go on fighting.
Although you know that every day,
which the war still lasts,
means new destruction to your homeland,
new danger in new hardships to your family.
You go on fighting.
Although it is clear that the only people interested in the pro prolongation of
the war,
someone's going to read that in a second language.
I can't even read prolongation of the war are the party leaders who want to at
any price the consequences,
which the Nazi defeat is inevitably going to have for them personally.
In other words,
we're going to hang them.
Uh,
remember that your dear ones want you back alive.
Remember also that there is only one safe way home the way through allied
captivity.
You know,
we had a lot of balls dropping these after we were firebombing fucking cities,
Huh?
Yeah.
You know,
I know we just burned.
You're all fucking city to the ground and evidently he didn't die screaming in
agony.
A,
the only way for you to avoid that is to,
uh,
become our prisoner.
According to the Geneva Conventions,
which has been recognized by Brazil,
you will have the following,
uh,
privileges in allied captivity.
Oh,
Jesus.
This is,
this is the classic checks in the fucking mail.
You will be removed immediately from the battle zone.
You will get the same food as allied troops.
If six sick,
you will be treated in the same hospitals as our soldiers.
And after the end of the war,
you will go home as soon as possible.
Well,
that's pretty vague.
As soon as we,
uh,
decide when you can fucking leave.
Did anybody believe a word of that?
I didn't.
I wouldn't do it.
I was like,
you know what the fuck you want these fucking guys are doing.
They want us to surrender
because they don't want us to kill more of them.
They're just going to fucking kill us.
You know what I take?
Well,
it's,
yeah,
he speaks the truth.
Um,
that was me in a foxhole with a Boston accent talking to somebody who sounds
like Hans and Franz.
How'd you like that?
He didn't think that was coming on the old podcast.
They did you,
um,
fuck did I start talking about World War II leaflets?
I was talking about buying a frying pan.
Oh yeah.
So I get down the street driving down the old road there.
Okay.
It's a Sunday evening.
I'm like,
you know what,
I'm going to knock this shit out before Monday comes around and all these
assholes have to go to work.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
I'm sorry.
It's an election year.
All these hard work and uh,
Joe six backs,
they put that Vance on one layer.
Um,
anybody who's in my ways and ask is there either a cunt.
Okay.
And I wish I was more enlightened to realize that I'm just impatient.
But,
uh,
that's,
you know,
it hasn't happened yet.
So anyways,
so I'm driving down the fucking road,
cruising along,
you know,
and all of a sudden,
they're doing road construction and it's just this massive fucking traffic jam.
And I knew I had to do the podcast tonight cause I'm doing some bullshit
tomorrow morning and I'm just like,
it can,
you can get this fucking city.
Can it just ever give me a fucking break?
You know,
I gotta tell you something.
All these shit where they talk about new Yorky,
you know if I can,
yeah.
Oh that shit.
You know,
they're always blow in New York about how fucking difficult it is.
I got to tell you.
Okay,
there's an outsider from Massachusetts.
I've lived in both places.
New York is definitely has its of grinding you down,
but there is no place like fucking Los Angeles do this,
this fucking city.
It's just,
it's brutal.
It's just fucking,
it never,
never lets up,
you know.
And then the whole time you're just bacon in the son of the exact same weather
every fucking day.
And everybody in the east coast comes out here and they're like here for five,
six days.
Oh my God,
this is great.
This is great.
Yeah,
there's great for six days it's fucking great.
But every day,
waking up that fucking Sun,
Sun,
burn it down on your fucking head.
I'm telling you this fucking place.
And you combine that with being in this business that I'm in trying to fucking
move ahead.
It is.
It is brutal.
Fucking brutal and all that shit.
You know?
I can't tell you how many fucking New York comedians have moved out here and
then moved back.
I moved back.
First Time I came out of it,
I couldn't take it.
I was like,
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
I'm telling you,
they're always so,
oh,
you know New York is so fucking real.
I'll fuck you.
Fuck you.
Bullshit.
You couldn't take it.
He couldn't take it and you wanted to move back to your familiar surroundings.
The only be 20 minutes away from your grandmother's special sauce.
That's why the fuck you moved back.
All right.
You're dumb fucking leather coat.
The pizza sucks out here.
You know,
I'm telling you,
if I devote,
which is a tougher city to live in,
I would definitely say Los Angeles over in New York.
It is.
Fuck yeah,
dude.
This said fucking catches on fire out here.
There's mudslides,
this fucking earthquakes,
you know,
in New York,
what's great about,
but I'm just talking basically trying to make it in show business to live in New
York,
in show business,
which is what is great about it is,
is you can get on the subway in,
stand amongst a bunch of regular people,
real people,
right?
And then you get to feel this feeling that,
that you're real,
that you're not this big showbiz fucking phony.
Who wants their own Goddamn TV show in New York.
It's so fucking real.
Look at that chair.
Look out real.
That fucking chair is right.
Um,
I just think because you know,
everybody's all mixed into fucking gather.
He ride on the subway that these New York showbiz people,
they just automatically think that they're there.
You know,
everybody here is all plastic and phony because you come out to la and the whole
place looks like a fucking movie set,
right?
You sit there,
you know,
you'd ride on the subway and you sit next to some fucking,
I don't know,
some construction worker,
union guy with this hired head getting ready and you start,
yeah,
I one of these guys now.
Now you're not,
you're in show business.
You're a big fucking phony,
right?
You're on your way to puppeteer school or whatever the fuck it is.
You're doing your little song and dance because you don't want to have a job.
Sorry,
I shouldn't have said all that shit.
But you know,
I really shouldn't have said that.
And having seen all the bullshit that I've seen,
like,
you know,
uh,
Bernie Sanders talking about her,
I don't know what the fuck he was talking about.
Like,
I don't think it's,
you know,
a good way to try to bring black and white people together by talking about how
white people have never lived in a ghetto.
Because automatically you just going to put them into a defensive posture where
they're going,
they're going to sit there and think about all the shit that they've gone
through and then they get,
and then they're going to get upset.
You know what I mean?
Um,
yeah.
I don't,
generally speaking,
white people do not live in ghettos.
Although I had to think other races of people do not live in the middle of
fucking nowhere off the Appalachian trail.
You know,
washing their clothes in a fucking bathtub,
sharing a pair of shoes,
some of that fucking horrific poverty that I've seen,
um,
that most of these fucking politicians will never see.
I don't think it's one of these fucking politicians.
They should go on the road and open for a fucking comedian who's traveling to
all these different,
that you will see.
Shit.
You can't fucking believe.
You'll see levels of poverty you can't fucking believe exist in this country.
Um,
I don't want to name cities,
but a,
there's some places down South Jesus Christ,
I don't know.
One time I drove from Indianapolis to Nashville and there was some place in
southern Kentucky.
I was running out of gas and I pulled over and they'll fucking humanity.
My God,
I swear to God,
there was something in the fucking drinking water.
I've never seen it.
It was just like I do.
I describe these people without just absolutely insulting them.
Um,
I dunno,
it was just like,
uh,
you know,
when somebody is like so dumb,
you get nervous.
You know,
they start talking to you and they're looking at you and you're,
you can tell they're just smart enough that they know that you think that
they're dumb and you're trying not to fucking give it away.
You know,
she just kind of puts your eyebrows up like,
Oh yeah,
you tried to get out of the fucking conversation.
Yeah.
It was like an entire gas station of that.
Even the person running the gas station,
um,
and this was off a major highway.
You know,
there was a subway,
you know,
when you drive in the middle of nowhere,
you don't ever go into just some fucking,
you know,
mom and pop place.
You don't want to do that.
What you do is you stay,
you stay brand loyal.
You pull into the Mcdonald's,
right?
You get gas at the fucking Sunoco or whatever.
You keep it fucking,
yeah.
You want to get breakfast?
Let's do you want to try the [inaudible] fucking pop place where everyone's
going to fucking turn around and look at you or we go into Denny's,
you know?
Um,
anyways,
I really should be talking about politics because I literally do not watch any
of it.
Um,
I know that was all that bullshit with Trump.
I don't understand why,
but people won't let Trump speak.
And how you feel that that's going to derail his campaign.
I think if anything,
it will just strengthen it.
Um,
I'm sure there's probably plenty of Trump people that don't like what Bernie
Sanders or Hillary saying they're not going in there and literally disrupting
the whole fucking thing.
Right?
I Dunno.
Just seems stupid to me.
He sees a fucking reality TV show star.
Just let the guy talk who gives a shit.
He's not really saying anything.
He's appealing to some people.
Who the fuck votes in a primary anyways,
aren't you guys like,
may I vote once every fucking four years?
I hate to say it,
but I do.
I vote one.
I vote for president.
That's why vote for him.
I always vote for the fucking third party person.
Although I don't know about Bernie Sanders.
I don't know if I'm going to fucking vote for this guy.
I'm just sick,
you know?
Hey,
you know we're going to take all the money from fucking these 10 people and gave
it to all you guys cause all you guys deserve it,
right?
No,
you guys are lazy.
Come to,
don't want to pull their own weight.
Your angels did.
Everybody got there is devils right?
That dumb shit.
It's just as extreme.
It's fucking Donald Trump to the left.
I can't listen to any of it.
And then sitting right in the fucking middle,
drafted behind both of them is all fucking square head herself.
Hillary Clinton,
she's gonna fuck.
She's going to go right in underneath,
right in underneath.
She's going to get in there and you're going to have listened to that fucking
busted trumpet for fucking the next four years.
Fucking filthy,
filthy family.
I don't like any of them.
All three of them.
You know what?
You have a seat on the Donald Trump show when he does like a combo firing.
You know what,
you'll find you're fucking fired and you're fired.
That's what I would like to do with the three of them tossed him in the fucking,
I can say that hat on because I only vote once every four years and I do not
watch the debates.
All right,
so,
you know,
I'm standing on farm ground here.
Such a dope.
Hey,
you know what I did do?
Um,
God knows it wasn't read something.
Uh,
I,
um,
I watched on Netflix,
I watched that Ukraine documentary a winter on fire.
It,
um,
okay.
You know,
it was just one of those things where it's just like Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
I knew I wasn't politically active,
but watching what these people did,
what they turned around,
I'll,
I'll try to give you a simple version of what happened,
which,
you know,
with my brain,
that's all you're going to get is basically what happened,
I guess around 2003,
2004,
uh,
there was some fucking Russian dude,
pro Russian dude each claim that he won the fucking election and they were like,
no,
you didn't,
you a piece of shit.
You're rigged it.
And they proved it and he got bounced on 2009.
The same dude comes back and guess what?
He wins the election like that wasn't corrupt.
So anyways,
you,
the Ukraine is a chance to join the European Union,
right?
To start being more like a European country and for once and for all get out
from underneath,
uh,
whatever you call,
whatever.
Russia has a dictatorship.
So the fucking Russian dude who allegedly got elected legitimately,
you know,
listens to the people and they say that that's what we want to do.
We don't want to take a step towards Russia.
We want to become part of the European Union.
We want to have a future here.
Like,
um,
what we see going on in western Europe and all of the fucking politicians go,
you got it.
All right.
The people have spoken.
We're going to do what you said.
And what do you think happened?
Right?
In the midnight hour they gave him,
they all right.
They have Fred.
They're like,
yeah,
you know what,
when not signed to that,
and,
uh,
we've been go hang out with though.
Vladi daddy over there.
Putin,
Vladimir Putin,
and,
and uh,
we're going to fucking shoot 18 holes of golf with him and we're going to sell
out your country to the risky.
So
started off this whole fucking revolution.
I'm not going to say what the fuck.
I mean,
you gotta watch it.
It's unbelievable.
But um,
you know,
I mean,
it's not like it's not in the news.
they ended up winning.
They somehow ended up winning and these,
these fucking people had no weapons.
They were just getting shot at what,
when I don't understand.
I mean,
I do understand it,
but I,
I,
there's no place in the world where you can protest.
You can't do it.
You protest,
cops show up and they beat the fuck out of you until you go home and they
arrested a few and then that's it.
Everyone,
it happens in this country,
this country with all its own would have free brave freedom of speech.
You know those fucking occupy Wall Street people,
right?
They come down there,
they beat the fuck out of them.
And everybody knows the old trick,
the same shit that they was,
they were claiming they did it in the Ukraine where it basically,
when you have a peaceful demonstration,
it's like,
well fuck,
we can't beat the fuck out of him.
What should we do?
They hire a couple people to go down there and pretend to be the protesters.
They throw a couple of fucking rocks and then the,
the,
the cops go nuts.
And then on the news they're like,
ah,
the protesters started attacking the police.
You know,
the police were just doing their job,
but bla bla bla bla.
The police's job is to go down there and beat the fuck out of him.
Right.
Isn't it?
Isn't that what it is that Jesus Christ built?
I Dunno.
Pill.
What?
What do you know?
I don't know.
That's,
that's kind of what I got out of it.
I got out of it that,
um,
it was an amazing documentary that these people actually with basically no
fucking weapons and just,
you know,
died,
lost their eyes,
had all these horrific fucking injuries.
Got Kidnapped,
disappeared,
all of this horrific shit,
and they were able to,
um,
hold them off for a while.
So then the fucking Russian guy ends up having to leave,
right?
He fucking leaves.
And then the AA,
Aa is a jolly good fellow.
It's all fucking over.
And then all of a sudden,
out of nowhere,
this,
this other revolution starts with people who are pro Russia.
So once again,
all they did was they just had Russian troops pretend to be Ukrainians and say,
wait a minute,
we don't want to be free.
We to be oppressed.
Right?
So now I guess they got a fight,
that thing.
And since then,
since the document you'd been made,
like 6,000 Ukrainian people died.
But um,
well,
I,
I don't understand why a,
yeah,
if you just look at the United States of America,
the amount of money you can still make,
if you're up on top,
the amount of taxes you can get out of paying the amount of parks that you can
fucking have and just pass it onto the middle class.
I don't understand why,
like why Russia still does the whole fucking a dictated thing or why any country
does just set it up the way we set it up.
You pretend that people,
you know,
you give them,
you let them be as free as they could be,
you know?
Yeah.
You do the whole rhetoric and the end,
but basically there is still a ruling class and you don't have to pay your fair
share and all that fucking shady works out and we know you're doing it.
But as long as you know,
you let us drive down the street and the convertible,
you know,
listening to some tunes,
man,
I mean,
somebody's got to run it.
I don't want to fucking do that shit.
You know,
all of a sudden make decisions.
I don't even like run in my own website.
There's no fucking way I could be sitting there making decisions for an a whole
goddamn country.
I don't want to do that.
Okay.
You know what,
uh,
what the,
what are the,
what is,
what does that like every fucking day waking up and not a God damn problem.
That's why I think things such why you can't have a dictator.
That's why they're all so brutally mean.
After a while they just get sick of answering questions.
Why?
What's the problem where I have just fucking shoot him.
All right.
I don't,
I don't care.
I said fucking shovel up the rest up.
What am a jail?
Okay.
Fuck.
I've got to do everything around here,
chicken here and about it.
Um,
anyways,
so if you get a chance,
I'll try to say here is,
if you get a chance to check out a Ukraine winter on fire and um,
I dunno,
I,
I should really start paying attention to politics more,
but I,
I just think it's all bullshit.
I can't,
I can't sit there and listen to it.
I start screaming at the fucking TV.
MMM.
And I get all fucking upset.
So why would I do that?
And then I ended up with three fucking options,
none of which I want.
You know,
I do have to tell you,
watching all fat boy,
they're from New Jersey,
Jesus Christ.
The look on his face when he was fucking listening to Donald Trump.
That was the funniest fucking shit ever.
That looks like a shotgun wedding.
It all he was thinking is that I'm fucking fuck do I get it?
I get myself into this.
How do I get out of this it?
Oh
yeah,
Jesus Christ.
How much did he fucking binge eat that night?
Poor guy.
That's really bad.
It's gotta be,
you know what sucks about being fat is people just know it.
You know,
you can't hide that shit and just boom,
they just fucking right on it.
You know what?
Me All,
I guess we,
I'm a baldheaded motherfucker,
so I got that now.
But when I was younger,
well then I had orange hair orange then turned red.
Yeah.
You know,
I kind of got shit the whole time,
you know,
if I really look back at it,
um,
all right.
Save you just some regular brown hair.
Brunette fucking,
you know,
I'm just,
when you think about Chinese people,
right?
Cause they don't,
they are there any red headed,
like naturally redheaded,
naturally aspirated.
Um,
Chinese people hang on a second here.
Natural red head,
Chinese
nine natural redheads from different backgrounds.
The forever war.
Why a Chinese girl has red hair?
Well,
because there was a fucking military base nearby,
I would think.
All right.
The forever war.
Why a Chinese girl has red hair.
When you zoom out of history to the level where empires rise and fall and people
migrate,
conquer,
collapse and absorb and disappear,
you find that the story is always the same.
That what
the tall stock tie stock.
The original stock is light non black hair.
Non Brown eyes.
Fair skin.
Okay.
Where am I on a racist website?
Don't fuck.
Am I reading here?
MMM.
The others are darker.
The others are weaker but breed faster up.
There we go.
Yeah.
I saw the red flags.
The fuck is the name of this website.
Kalanik soul life to the neanderthal death to the void.
Yeah.
Christus rex.
The forever war.
Why a Chinese girl has red hair.
Oh God.
Fucking Internet is amazing and I just affected his,
gives every clued me just punch a fucking dopes.
Why are blonde and red hair clothes not seen?
Can an Asian and a natural redhead?
If I have a redheaded Asian look at this shit,
the redheaded Chinese girl,
Asian red hair on Pinterest,
the world's first Asian redheads.
So I'm going to go out on a limb and say that they don't really don't have any
blondes or any of that type of shit.
So I was just thinking,
do you think that people get less shit?
Like what are you get bullied for
in,
uh,
in China?
Oh God,
please let there be some fucking native Chinese people.
Listen to this.
What are the,
give me the top fucking 10 reasons that Chinese people get bullied in China.
It's probably a usual shit economic that's going to be looks right.
There's always going to be better looking mediocre.
And then there was always going to be some poor bastard coming down the street.
You know,
some fucking happen.
I don't know,
something that's going on with his nose,
his fucking ears.
There's a there,
the kids,
they'll,
they'll find something you,
but you would think,
you know,
if everybody just had the fucking jet black hair,
and maybe I'm more overly sensitive to this because I just came,
you know,
I came on,
I came to the world with a bullseye.
Right,
right there.
There you go.
What the fuck is that?
Get it right.
MMM.
This has been a fucking crazy podcast,
huh?
I don't,
and I don't have any advertising yet.
I,
this is usually the time that I tap out and I started fucking reading,
but it hasn't come in yet.
It has not come in yet.
Let me see.
I'll look it up right now.
See if I got it.
Why do I only have 50 fucking windows open now?
I got a French book here that I was reading.
I wasn't reading,
I was listening to it.
There's a book,
something about a wolf that wanted to change its colors.
I've gone 15 or 16 straight days on a duo.
Lingo asked me to say something in French.
I can't really,
but you know what?
I can read it pretty well.
MMM.
For,
I know that that means for children.
Poor on false children.
All right.
What am I doing?
I'm on completely losing my train of thought here.
Oh fuck you.
Something.
There's a window.
This is the amount of shit.
I look out one window.
I have French school books.
All right.
And then the next window I have critical engine opened up on a Wikipedia.
I was talking to Paul Versey cause we're doing this tour and I was saying like,
all right,
these are going to be like four or five hour drives or we could rent a small
plane but it's going to be maybe two to sin Paul's music.
Oh,
I know.
I like,
I like small planes starts freaking the fuck out,
right?
Like small planes sticking.
It's like a Chevy Chevette some piece of shit.
Like it's not just going to die.
And I was saying like,
dude,
there's going to be a dual engine.
We're going to be fucking fine.
Uh,
you got two engines.
It to the odds are them both fucking failing at the same time and one of them
can still fly the plane.
You find this is what I believed.
But then I started looking it up cause I was trying to give them some
information.
I was saying like,
look,
I mean I don't know 100% know this ship,
but this is what I've basically been told.
And a,
I started looking it up and evidently,
uh,
one engine for the most part is more critical than the other.
And also when one engine goes out,
it isn't like he just keep flying at normally.
Whoa.
You know,
we still got one.
We're good like that.
Obviously,
you know,
it fucks with the not the balance.
What would it be?
I don't know how to say it scientifically.
It's not a jet engine.
So there's no like thrust is there
of Jesus Christ.
Can you believe I have a pilot's license?
Fucking,
I believe art.
Um,
let's read this here.
Uh,
the critical engine of a multi engine fixed wing aircraft is the engines whose
failure would most adversely affect the performance or handling abilities of an
aircraft on propeller aircraft.
There is a difference in the remaining young and that's just the nose going
right to left moments after failure of the left or the right outboard engine.
When all propellers rotate in the same due to the p factor.
And I was like,
what the fuck is the p factor?
And it has something to do with like when you're flying straight and level
flight,
okay.
Your propeller blades are um,
you know,
they're there.
Uh,
you have the angle of attack with the wind.
It's basically coming straight.
You're perpendicular to the angle of attack of the wind.
That way you are getting the most bang for your buck with,
for the work that the engine is doing with the propellers.
But the more you angle nose up or nose down,
the more the wind,
the way it's hitting.
It affects the performance is what I sorta belief.
I've got all this Mumbo jumbo in my fucking head.
I have no idea.
But I had no,
so I started reading more about this and there's all these fucking debates.
You know,
I was always of the belief that if you had two engines,
if you could afford to engines,
you buy that fucking airplane because you know,
the engines run independently.
So you've got to fucking engines.
What are the odds of both of them?
One fails and then the other one fucking fails,
you know,
but it's,
it's so it's gotta be almost zero.
However,
there's all these that I could,
you know,
something I started to read about it and there was all these debates where at
first it was obviously believed that yeah,
more engines is better,
it's safer.
And then somewhere along the line somebody did a study and saw that more fatal
action,
uh,
accessing more fatal accidents happened in dual engine aircraft.
And people going like,
oh,
and then so maybe a single is better.
And then that person came back and was like,
no,
you weren't hearing what I was trying to say.
I was actually saying it was safe.
And then it doubled back on itself and I have no fucking clue what is safe.
But what I did learn in it in a very layman kind of way was I had no idea that,
um,
I mean it does make sense if you just have one side working,
you know that it'd be sort of pulling that side along of the aircraft more so
than the other one causing the other one.
The drag.
And I,
you'd have to,
I dunno,
crab your way into the fucking wind.
I have no idea.
But all I know is I was reading it says if one of your engines dies and the
other one's still going,
you obviously have a much,
they said a much better chance of making it to the airport.
They didn't say you would make it though.
And a witch.
Here's my question to anybody out there who might know this shit
on,
uh,
on your average twin engine airplane,
can boat both engines independently fly the airplane?
You know what I mean?
With one quit.
Do they both have the ability to,
uh,
basically gets you,
have you flying fast enough where you can still maintain lift,
you know,
cause then I was then thinking like,
okay,
well if they went from one to two engines,
you know,
you're adding more weight to the aircraft.
Like as you'd build a bigger fucking plane.
Sorry,
I'm trying to do this math in my head.
You build a bigger fucking plane.
But my thing is is do they then go all because of certain aircraft?
Because it's a cheaper twin engine.
It's the both engines in unison have enough power so you can maintain lift.
But if you lose one of them,
the other one can still give you the hundred percent of the lifts that you need.
You actually only have like 60%.
If you still have the critical engine or only 40% of the critical one goes out.
Like I have no idea how that works.
All I know is it scared the fuck out of me.
That's all I can tell you.
Um,
all right.
Is it an amazing the amount of topics I can talk about that.
I have no fucking idea.
It's incredible.
Like we're,
we're,
we're going to be doing some more here in the last half hour,
this podcast.
Um,
I guess now I'm just going to say that I'm going to stop here and read some
advertising.
I don't have it,
but a,
you're going to hear it now because a,
you're listening to this and the fucking few.
Okay.
Dollar Shave Club.
Everybody,
I'm recording this on my phone if it sounds fucked up.
All right.
Dollar Shave club.com has a special offer for a new members,
for new members who join today.
You'll get a free month of the executive razor when you buy a tube of doctor
cabbies.
Um,
so first time they've ever done something like this and once you try dollar
shave club.com you'll become a proud member like millions of others.
Uh,
one reason is because they deliver amazing razors right to your door for a third
of the price of what those greedy cut razor corporations charge.
That means when you joined dollar Shave Club,
you can afford to shave with a fresh blade any time you fucking goddamn well
feel like,
and it feels fantastic.
You'll get a first class shave when you use the executive blade without hurting
your wallet.
Another reason is their doctor cavities easier.
Uh,
using it with the executive,
uh,
makes the blade glide gently over the smoothest shave ever.
Hey,
you might want to shave you a balls with it.
Don't do that.
Nobody at fucking Skin Shave Dollar Shave Club is saying to fucking do that.
That was a joke.
Okay?
Drop your razor and wash the coffee.
Shave butter off of your ball bag.
Do not do it.
All right,
back to the ED.
Um,
Dr Carver's,
easy shave butter isn't your average shaving cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula with high quality natural ingredients
leaving.
You're leaving your skin unbelievably soft and smooth.
And right now,
members who buy a tube of shave butter,
get the executive razor razor for free.
They've never done this before.
Take advantage of it.
And it's the,
Oh,
it's only available by going to dollar shave club.com/burr.
That's dollar shave club.com/ [inaudible] all right,
what's up next?
Oh,
here we go.
Are Old friends are back headspace,
man.
Um,
let's honest,
most of you,
most of your problems start with your mind.
Jesus.
I know mine.
Do fear,
anger,
stress,
anxiety,
depression and sleeplessness and freckles.
They begin in your head taking regular life.
Um,
please include all the following points during your read.
I will,
I always do.
Um,
but it doesn't have to be that way.
You can make a major difference in just 10 minutes a day.
This change comes through through guided meditation with the new headspace APP.
Headspace man is meditation made simple.
It's guided meditation that you listen to whenever you want,
wherever you want,
right on your phone,
computer or tablet.
Beditation is rooted in thousands of years of tradition and we've boiled,
we've boiled it down to an APP that we hope a bigger corporation will someday by
.
So we came,
we can take the money,
get some hookers,
and a bunch of blow with thousands of scientific studies that show its positive
effects,
like improving focus and relationship harmony in decreasing anxiety and stress.
Join over 5 million users already using some headspace man for free right now.
For sure.
Download for free headspace,
the headspace APP and again to take their take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation@headspace.com slash bar why don't I ever do this?
I need to do this.
I'm out of my fucking mind.
Their headspace.
Take 10 program as a hundred percent freeway to experience the benefits of
meditation and you're busy,
modern life.
Train your mind for a healthier,
less stress life.
That would be great for me.
You know,
I'd stop screaming at people.
I wouldn't be funny anymore and I'd become homeless,
but God damn it.
I'd be happy now.
Seriously,
I want to do this.
headspace.com/birth that's headspace.com/ [inaudible] hey man,
headspace.com/ [inaudible]
fuck.
There's two more.
I hate this.
I hate doing these trunk club no matter what time of year it is.
Yeah,
you gotta make every second count.
Uh Oh shit.
I need to look good with this zipper.
And that means looking your best.
No more ratty jeans are oversized hoodies.
You're dressed like a fucking douche.
Gee,
you want to be great.
If a trunk full of clothes would come your way.
Sure.
I know how you could do it.
Trunk Club,
Trunk Club takes the Hassles,
man out of shopping.
Find the best clothes for you and your style,
your look and feel amazing.
And you'll always have the perfect close for the season,
but I don't want to go to a fucking mall.
Well,
that's the point of this shit.
At Trunk club.com/borrower you answer simple questions about your style,
your preferences,
your size,
and you're assigned and expert,
stylist,
you styles is going to go pick up all the shit that you asked for.
Then they're going to send you the fucking trunk.
You sift through it,
you keep the shit you like,
you give the shit back that you don't like in their prepaid fucking trunk.
Bing,
Bang,
boom.
You never have to go to a mall again.
You're going to look great and God damn you look great.
You feel great.
Maybe it'll sell.
It'll suck your Dick.
Ah,
maybe you'll find your prince charming.
Sorry,
I had to cut through all the copy.
Get started today at Trunk Club and a,
they'll style you for free post trunk free shipping both ways.
You only pay for the clothes that you keep.
Take advantage.
Go to trunk club.com/burr that's trunk club.com/ [inaudible] for a trunk filled
with clothes.
You're going to love.
You don't have to go to the mall.
It's a fucking joke.
Why?
You're not doing it?
I don't know.
All right.
Blue Apron,
everybody.
You need to know how to cook.
Okay.
It's time you grow up and learn how to cook.
Not only do you feel like you know your way around a kitchen,
Ooh,
who still in Southie,
but cooking at home means eating healthier and saving more money instead of
ordering out expensive takeout.
Again,
payment.
Where do you start?
Well,
don't worry.
Blue Apron as you covered for less than $10 per meal.
Blue Apron,
blue apron delivers all fresh ingredients,
all the fresh ingredients you need to create home cooked meals.
Just follow the easy step by step instructions.
Um,
each meal can be prepared in 40 minutes or less.
No overwhelming trips to the grocery store and no more sad take out,
no matter your dietary preferences.
Blue Apron makes it a breeze to discover and prepare dishes like smokey maple,
miso glazed salmon with what?
Udon noodles or die noodles.
You Diane Noodles.
You'd on doodles.
U D o n noodles,
mushroom Kaylen cheese case,
a dia gross,
gross mushroom and Carolyn cheese.
It's like watching a fat he paste.
How about chicken and cheese?
I with lame sesame,
avocado,
radishes and salsa.
Great.
Now when you're on coach kitchen,
you can cook with the grease that you've never used before.
Like watermelon,
radishes,
feral far.
Oh fuck.
Oh,
I don't know what it is with purple potatoes and recipes are between five and
700 calories,
so you won't become a fat fuck delicious and good for you right now.
You can get your first two meals for free@blueapron.com slash [inaudible] that's
blue apron.com/bar height,
blue apron.com/bar.
You know what?
It's a better way to cook,
God dammit.
And then you go back to them podcasts yet.
Cons in the future.
All right.
Um,
oh,
I didn't even finish the fucking,
I'm back.
We're back after the advertising.
We are back I guess.
Did I read it then?
I sound good.
How much did I stumble?
I never even finished the frying Pan Story.
So I get all the way down to the fucking frying pan thing.
All right.
And we already have like the regular whatever,
a 10 inch one.
So I want to buy the eight inch one that matches.
And of course the only way to do that is that to buy the whole fucking set.
Okay.
You know,
and I was just like,
you know what?
Fuck you.
And I bought one of those little pasta cutter thinks and that was it.
And I fucking left and I couldn't for the life of me could understand.
One of them was nine 95 the other one was 21 bucks.
And I sat there for 10 minutes holding both of them,
trying to see like what does it handle better?
How is this one more than twice the price?
I Dunno.
Bill,
why would you think it's interesting to us?
I don't know.
Trying to fill up a fucking hour here.
Um,
by the way,
I got some,
I am,
do have some dates and I will never again announced cities,
um,
that I,
that I'm saying,
you know,
we're working on it.
I'm never going to do that again.
Like I said,
what I said with buffalo and fucking Syracuse because that hasn't worked out
yet.
Now everybody's like,
dude,
what the fuck you said you will come in there.
I shouldn't open my big Yap.
All right.
Um,
I am coming to Albany.
I do know that.
So people in Buffalo,
like,
dude,
that's like a four hour fucking drive.
I know,
I know.
I'm sorry.
All right,
I'll,
I'll figure something out.
All right,
here we go on match 25th.
I'm in Riverside,
California,
Riverside,
which I believe is the beginning of the inland empire or maybe it isn't.
I have no idea.
Um,
on the 26th,
I'm at the terrorist theatre in Long Beach,
California.
Unbelievable honor to be playing in a place that is the place who Richard Pryor
taped live in concert where he had the red shirt,
the black pants in the silver shoes.
I will be standing on that stage.
I'm sure they redid it since he's been there,
you know,
so I won't be standing on the exact same floorboards,
but I will be within the same structure.
I'd be standing in the same place where he did stand up comedy to me,
the greatest standup comedian of all time on the 22nd of April.
I will be in Saint Louis.
Uh,
the Oh it go y'all on the 24th.
He's a great ones.
I will be in Iowa in Ames,
Iowa,
22nd St Louis,
Missouri and the 24th.
I'll be in ames,
Iowa.
I have not been an ios since I did the rich bitch tour way back in 2004.
Um,
speaking of which did anybody's think?
One of the guys that did the tour with Donnell Rawlings?
Did you see that TMZ video?
The guy's getting breakfast.
He's got a $12 check.
He goes outside to have a cigarette.
He leaves his bag inside and all of a sudden they came running out in Philly
screaming and I'm thinking he was,
he was dining and dashing showing it as we used to call it in Boston.
You know what I mean?
Fucking unbelievable.
Unbelievably.
Ends up getting in a big fucking fight knowledge,
and he's got his bag and side.
They won't give it to him.
MMM.
According to this shit that I read,
I was just fucking,
I believe,
and I can tell you that as a white guy,
that would not happen to me.
That would not happen to me.
Um,
that was,
that was fucked up.
Definitely fucked up.
And uh,
you know what?
It didn't happen in Boston.
All right.
All you fucking haters that happened in Philly,
say it's all around.
MMM.
You know,
it was funny.
Donald threw that punch in.
The dude caught it.
The next time I see him,
I'm going to tease him about that.
I wouldn't do it now because it's fucking fresh and it was bullshit.
I can,
I can definitely tell you as a white dude,
uh,
that you know,
that not would not have happened to me.
That's a complete racial profiling incident.
Put it was dead fucking dude.
Lean back and just caught it.
You know,
you ever see a pitcher?
Just catch a fucking one that comes right back to the mound.
He did that.
But with Don Ellis fist,
um,
anyways,
uh,
plowing ahead.
Uh,
May 7th,
Orlando,
Florida,
May 8th.
I'll be in Jacksonville,
Florida.
And a clear,
what are you staring at me for?
Once the matter.
I'm not,
I already gave you fod,
so let me look at me like that and I already took you out.
Um,
well you just want attention buddy.
You're getting lonely over there,
Huh?
All right.
Fucking dog is so needy.
Portland May,
June 4th,
2016 I'll be there.
Uh,
and I also know I,
in the early April,
I got a bunch of Canadian dates.
Uh,
they're all up on my website.
[inaudible] DOT com.
Um,
so anyway,
speaking of dogs,
I kind of tweeted about this shit where,
um,
you know what?
The fucking dog I have the biggest problem with like their owners never have
them under control.
I'm not blaming the breed here,
but there's just something about the fucking the owners and how hyper the dog is
,
is those fucking giant portals.
There was another one today.
I was at the supermarket in this person that tied it up outside and it's just
literally outside the fucking supermarket the whole time.
Wow.
Wow,
wow.
We just would not stop.
Sorry.
Get my dog all amped up.
Um,
those fucking dogs are insane.
I don't know what the deal is with them,
be they,
I think they are like,
they're kind of like greyhounds.
I'd really just think you need to run them around a fucking track for an hour
everyday just to get them to get it out of their system.
But they got like that perm going on.
So I don't think anybody really thinks it's an issue.
Cleo,
what are you doing?
You're going to distract me on the podcast.
You can't be this adorable right now.
Okay.
For those who don't know anything about pit bulls,
they are like the most needy fucking like love bugs.
They're ridiculous.
Like she just wants to crawl up here in fucking put her head in my lap and go to
sleep.
You know what I mean?
She's not over in the corner of fucking doing some prison workouts,
thinking about,
you know,
people she wants to kill.
And that right buddy.
Now that I've stereotyped giant poodles,
I'm going to try to undo the damage with pit bulls who's getting hit.
My dog would try to rip your face off if he came into the fucking,
um,
and in the house.
She fucking parked at a guy yesterday and I actually loved every second of it.
I was sitting in my Prius on these mean streets of Los Angeles,
downtown Hollywood.
And uh,
some fucking degenerate came up to the window and uh,
I don't know what the fuck he's asking for money or booze or some shit.
And my dog just fucking flipped out,
flipped out,
and the guy jumped back and everything was great,
was like,
I have my own security.
Um,
and the guy was such a fucking alkie deep backed up off the car and then still
mind like,
I want to drink,
I'm trying to get some money for drinks.
I just,
you know,
I told him the beat it every once in a while I'd tell them to beat it.
You know,
there was a one legged homeless guy and he seemed like he was saying,
and he was talking to himself.
Maybe it was a little crazy,
but I will be talking to myself too if I had one fucking leg standing next to a
stop sign.
Right.
What else are you going to do?
There's nobody else there.
So him,
I gave money to
and I was actually joking to myself when I gave him the money and I drove away.
I go,
hi,
there's,
there's my good deed for the day.
Hey,
let's go in and rub and tug.
Yeah,
rub and tug.
I can't believe fucking people go to those places that don't you worry that the
cops are gonna show up any second.
You know,
you lie in there with the fucking woody,
right?
With a little fucking Woodrow Wilson,
Some girl fucking give you a little handy and all of a sudden everybody get down
on the ground,
you know,
you're like,
oh shit.
Right?
And what are you gonna do?
Say it was legal.
You're not a will that hard on to go away before that fucking dude comes in and
sees you with a half a stiffy,
you know,
I swear to God it hangs like that.
I was in here.
I had a problem with my shoulder,
man,
they're gonna rest you.
Is she a fucking half naked?
Okay.
Bring it down to the jail.
You're already ready to get fucked.
You don't even have any clothes on that.
He got an oil all over your body.
The fuck is wrong with you.
So anyways,
June 5th,
I'll be in Albany,
New York,
and a June 17th,
I'll be in Noah.
No,
we're fucking New Jersey at the,
uh,
New Jersey fucking performance arts center for the,
the fucking cock suck is there.
Um,
yeah.
You don't really make me happy.
The other day I was watching the NHL channel.
Obviously they were talking about how the Bruins could potentially get the
number one seed in the east.
Unfucking believable.
The job that closed Julian has done.
And I'll tell you something right now,
Dan Shaughnessy,
you remember last year when you were calling for his fucking head and saying
maybe he stayed here too long.
You all went on and you should write an apology article.
Unbelievable how these fucking sports writers,
because they got nothing else to write.
We'll,
we'll try to run out,
run out of town,
a fucking coach who brings us our first Stanley Cup and almost 40 fucking years.
Why would you do that?
Jesus fucking Christ.
All right,
let's,
uh,
let's read some of the,
the questions here for this week.
Oh,
we got an update.
I love when there's an update.
Remember last week the,
uh,
the granny fucking are.
Yeah.
Remember that story all right.
Here we got an update.
Hey,
they're all Billy fucking water.
I got an update for you on this one.
Uh,
the story has good news and bad news.
All right,
so last,
last,
for those of you who didn't listen,
I'll give you a little recap.
There was some kid,
uh,
you know,
he was,
he's basically,
he's engaged,
he's getting married in six weeks,
so he's over his fiance's house as his future in laws house or fucking parents.
That's all I'm trying to say.
Right?
So they're playing some card game and evidently they're down to the final hand
and he has,
uh,
the cards called granny water.
I don't know what the game is or whatever.
Some people sent me pictures of the car at the game does exist,
but it's a really high point card or whatever.
And he was laying down,
oh fuck them yarn and sorry,
he was laying down his car the last,
I basically,
when he laid it down,
he was going to do the old fucking right there.
Fred.
I won the game and uh,
he had the granny water cart and I guess in the end of the game is probably,
you get it,
you hold onto it and you played at a crucial point.
So everybody's sitting there as everybody's laying the cards down,
waiting to see who's going to fucking lay it down.
So this kid fucking finally his turn,
he lays it down to be like,
you know,
like hitting the last second three.
I just won.
And because he listens to the podcast,
instead of saying,
I got the grantee water card,
he goes,
look,
it's all fucking grant now.
He goes,
it's granny fucking wall.
And just screamed it
to his in laws.
Okay,
who never heard this guy curse before and do not listen to this podcast?
So they just stared at him like,
what?
What was that?
What is my daughter marrying?
Like he just completely screwed the whole fucking thing up.
So he's asking me for advice.
Should he bring it up?
Should he not bring it up?
All right,
now you guys are caught up.
Here you go.
He says the story has good news and bad news.
The good news is my fiance's parents were super cool about the whole things.
Um,
I,
I bit the bullet and waited until we went over for game night again last night.
I apologized,
of course,
and they said,
they initially just thought,
Whoa,
y'all your like this fuck.
They initially thought it was really odd for me to yell like that without
knowing,
without them knowing the context.
But once it was explained,
my fiance texted them about it.
It was no big deal.
It was a huge relief.
We played the game again and every time someone played that car,
they did the whole granny water thing minus the fucking in the middle.
Okay,
cool.
He goes,
so my embarrassment will be immortalized.
Uh,
the bad news is that I mentioned that you read the letter on the podcast.
Oh No.
You know what?
You're one of those guys.
Do you just like you just like stepping and shit.
He goes naturally.
They wanted to listen to it.
I thought it wasn't a big deal because they lived through the story and your
commentary was hilarious.
I warn them about the explicit nature of your podcasts and that there were
plenty of fucks throughout the fact that you did the granny water thing before
it was even brought up,
uh,
was perfect.
Everyone thought the story was hilarious.
That is until the p s
uh,
if you recall,
I may or may have not called Hillary Clinton a cont.
Uh,
Jesus,
that's right.
You did.
He goes,
yeah,
I know.
I'm a dumb ass bill.
My fiance just turned to me and said,
did you write that?
Uh,
he said,
my fiance turned to me and said,
did you write that with that look on her face?
I knew I was fucked.
So freckles.
I did the only thing I could,
I said,
oh,
sorry about that.
I didn't write it.
Bill's email screener.
Guy Did.
Andrew did,
he picks the emails each week,
then writes the little opening line,
pun and then sometimes throws in a ps to make them more entertaining.
When or why would you write this?
Cause if they listen to this,
you're fucked.
And you know what,
Dude,
I have no sympathy for you.
Say,
here we go.
He goes,
they bought it.
So we just listened to the rest and we're laughing again by the end.
So I through Andrew onto the bus on that one.
I'm going to repeat my only good move from the last story and just shut the fuck
up about it forever and the end all is well,
thanks for reading it on the podcast.
It seemed to help smooth it over.
No worries.
Just tell him not to listen to this one.
He goes,
by the way,
um,
I just bought tickets to your show and I'm not gonna say where the show is in
case anybody's figuring out who the fuck this is.
It's the week after my wedding and my fiance slash wife by that point is coming
too.
I'd love to meet you in person.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Uh,
all right,
well yeah,
I'll be hanging out after Iowa.
Just scream out.
Oh,
I just said where it was.
well you're fucked.
Grantee water screaming out and fucking say a to you.
All right.
Now everybody's gonna do that.
They're all right,
girlfriend,
leaving cleo.
Relax buddy.
Go cold you noses.
It's usually not cold at night.
You got a little gas left in the tank,
Huh?
You want to go?
Oh,
I know.
Okay.
I got it.
I'm not going to say the whole sentence.
I will.
I'm going to take you know who you know where when I'm done with this.
All right,
Cleo,
go lay down buddy.
Could you please lay down?
I don't have it in my heart to yell at you here.
All right,
cool.
Could you lay down your fucking bastard?
I love you to get out of here.
Go on.
Go on please.
Can you lay down please
cleo?
Yeah.
Step on all my shit.
As you go over there,
just go lay down
Jesus dog whisperer.
I am not.
Um,
oh,
by the way,
how about those fucking concert wounded warriors?
How much money did I give them?
If they're actual pieces of shit over there and they didn't give that fucking
money to wounded troops,
you know,
can I sue them to get the money back and then just give it to the fucking people
they were allegedly going to help?
Yeah,
I am really just,
I'm done.
I'm done with fucking charities.
I'm fucking done with them.
I just am eight.
Oh,
I'm going Donald Trump on this one.
I've seen two or three bad ones and now I'm judging all of them.
Fuck them.
Saint Jude,
I'm sticking with them.
Okay.
If they ended up turning foot,
they're bad then fuck all of them.
I'm just doing what I'm doing.
Why did the other day drove up to somebody with one leg at a stoplight,
observed that they weren't fucking wasted as much as I could tell in,
here you go.
You know,
even if they were,
I'd be drinking too if I had one leg right standing at a fucking stop sign.
Um,
I don't know what the stop sign has to do with it.
What was it?
A traffic light bill.
Well then,
you know,
maybe I have some yogurt,
um,
girlfriend leaving for religious mission,
a Billy Ball bag.
My girlfriend and I are both college students and although we haven't been
together for too long,
I could tell she is special in the way.
When you meet the one,
you just know she's the person I have.
She's the best person I've ever met.
Kind,
funny,
intelligent.
And on top of that just drop dead gorgeous.
What?
Jesus lock that down to.
Um,
if things seem to be too good to true,
what if things seem too good to be true?
Jesus Christ,
I have,
sorry,
I've got to have some form of fucking mild dyslexia or many even done,
but then I thought I use a reform.
Uh,
uh,
things seem too good to be true.
They are.
She's Mormon.
Oh
g
and she's leaving for her mission in July.
If you don't know.
Um,
Mormons,
I don't give a shit about Mormons and just anybody who's actively religious,
you know,
to the point it,
it,
it affects the decisions they make in life other than basic shit.
Like,
you know,
don't throw a rocket that guy,
cause you wouldn't want them to do it to you.
You know,
I,
I'm at one with that.
But when you know,
when you start forming other opinions on you fucker religion,
I don't know.
It starts to get a little,
a
little a scion taller Christian,
Judy [inaudible],
Buddha,
fucking Nizam,
whatever.
All of them.
Throw them all over and fucking Muslim.
Liam.
It's a big fucking pot and stick it on a fucking pot,
right?
Yeah,
there you go.
Show her the microwave from it.
Turn it on it.
Don't shut it off.
All right.
She's a Mormon and she's leaving for her mission in July.
If you don't know,
Mormons are a type of Christian.
I didn't know that,
and they send missionaries around the world to convert people into their
religion and she's getting sent to Zimbabwe.
Fucking Zimbabwe.
They leave for two years,
have to pay for everything themselves and aren't allowed to contact home the
entire time.
Why aren't they allowed to contact home the entire time?
That's fucking weird.
If she goes,
not only would that be the end of us,
but it's seriously hurts chances.
I've her future career aspiration,
we both wanted to become doctors.
I'm an atheist,
but I've recently found myself praying to Jesus that she doesn't actually go
because if and when she leaves,
that will be the end of it.
I don't know what to do.
Should I break things off now?
Should I try and convince her not to go?
Waiting is not an option for me because we'd be completely different people by
the time she gets back.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Um,
I dunno.
Do what?
I'm starting to think maybe she isn't the one for you.
If you're just going to,
you know,
if you have to debate telling her not,
should I just break it off or tell her not to go?
I mean,
I think if she really loved this woman,
you would you be going,
I'm just going to talk to her until I'm blue in the face
and tell her not to go.
And then even if she went,
you'd be thinking like,
well maybe you know,
you'd have a ray of light going,
well maybe to two years.
I Dunno if we agreed a fucking cool it for two years.
You know,
it's only two years.
When you look at the rest of your life,
you're Kinda like,
Eh,
we'd be two completely different people at jet.
Break it up now.
Yeah,
look,
she wants to go to Zimbabwe.
Let her,
you know,
to spread the fucking word of a whatever the fuck they're doing there.
Yeah.
Let her go.
Just,
you know,
if
somebody wants to go somewhere to go do something,
what are you gonna tell him not to go?
Go ahead.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Go,
go.
Spread the fucking dumb shit they put in your head and go,
go,
go spread it on the other side of the world's poor fucking Zimbabwe.
Peep Zimbabwean people.
Now you went fucking Zimbabwe.
You know I was assuming you meant because it's so far away you couldn't visit
her.
Let's see what's going on in Zimbabwe right now.
Zim.
Bob,
way as exactly how it should be spelled.
Z I m B A,
B,
Wwii.
I'd be such a great fucking speller if everything was spelled like Zimbabwe,
Zimbabwe,
Z ,
I m B,
a,
B,
Wwii,
Zimbabwe,
Zambia,
Bob.
We soon we'll be converting you to more men.
Do,
do,
do you got to go two years of your life to fucking for what?
Alright.
Zimbabwe.
Zimbabwe is a beautiful country in southern Africa that is known for its
dramatic a way,
way,
way would come on.
Oh,
this is the government.
This is the government websites.
So this is all the propaganda here.
Oh,
it's absolutely beautiful.
You can have your wallet and fucking tape to your chest.
No one will take it.
Everybody's wonderful down here.
Everybody's welcome.
Please come down and spend all your fucking money.
You know,
if you don't mind.
Okay.
Zimbabwe was voted the number one place in Zimbabwe to go three years in a row.
Wow.
Jesus,
look at that.
Fuck.
That puts an Agora falls to shame.
Holy Shit.
So Bob was a beautiful country in southern Africa that is known for its dramatic
landscapes.
It's diverse.
Wildlife,
see Cobras and tigers,
and it's hardworking people home to the Great Zimbabwe Monument,
the mighty Victorian falls and the majestic eastern highlands.
The country also boasts of worldclass national parks in which a variety of
animals,
including the big five can be found.
The big fat.
What the fuck are the big five?
Big Five.
I've got to go lion.
Who's your big five?
It's like the Chris rock movie.
Top Five.
Gimme a big five.
I'd say the Big Five.
You've got to go lion.
Tiger,
elephant doubt.
Doubt.
Right?
That's like Montana.
Brady can Johnny Unitas the third one?
You never know,
right?
Whatever they're there were in everybody's top five.
If you know anything about football,
right?
Alright.
Lion.
Tiger,
elephant,
hippos.
Rhinos.
Giraffes are big
gorillas.
Some big motherfuckers.
Hang on a second.
I've got to look up big five.
They see this.
This is,
how are you doing?
What?
You know,
I'm going to get the sports club big five sporting goods.
Big Five
animals in Africa.
All right.
In Africa,
the big five game animals are
the African lion.
Yeah.
The African elephant plan.
Like I says,
African,
you know like what it's supposed to,
what the Rhode Island one,
the one at that fucking zoo.
The Cape Buffalo.
Oh,
the African Leopard.
Ah,
and the white slash black rhinoceros.
All right,
so I've got three out of eight and said hippo.
Rhino.
Well,
when a fucks the Hippel big five game.
All right.
In Africa,
the big five game animals are American.
Okay.
The Lion,
the elephant,
the Buffalo,
the leopard,
and the rhinoceros.
Oh,
is this the thing that dentists paid to fly over and go fucking shoot these
things?
All right.
All right,
so there you go.
So we learned a little something here.
That's the big five.
The largest of these are the national park in the west and the something else
transfrontier park in the south has a total area of three or nines as an edge
then.
All right,
let's get to the,
let's get to the real questions.
Um,
Americans
welcomes
in Zimbabwe.
Yeah.
Did we do anything that out did,
did the upper 1% in this country piss them off?
All right.
Americans in Zimbabwe
that,
that at the de and I should say,
are you looking for fellow Americans in zip up?
No,
I'm not looking for a fucking pen pal.
Six things I had wrong because last thing I read about Zimbabwe here,
all right.
Six things I had wrong about traveling to Zimbabwe.
Look at those elephants.
Fuck it.
Love those things.
I cannot believe people kill those things.
How could you kill an elephant?
I couldn't kill any of those fucking things.
MMM.
All right.
The top five things.
Six things I had wrong about traveling to Zimbabwe and one I had right?
Number one,
Zimbabwe's dangerous.
Uh,
at Matador we believe most travel advisories in American perceptions of overseas
destination being dangerous are way overblown.
I enjoy visiting,
say Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
The big cities.
MMM.
The big cities are the most,
or where the most violent crime is concentrated like in the United States.
It wasn't a surprise that then that Victoria Falls as well as the couple
national parks we visited felt to just about as safe and as friendly as any
place can get.
In fact,
Victoria Falls has such a small town feel that,
uh,
other journalists joked,
it had the vibe of US national park in the off season.
All right,
cool.
Zimbabwe's wildlife has all been wiped out.
This was a big one for me.
I love seeing wildlife.
This is making me want to go there.
Three hyperinflation will make buying things a total hassle.
You have to sing years of new coverage,
hyperinflation,
and I was fixing him,
blah,
blah.
I'd have to carry around bricks of $10 $10 billion notes to buy a bunch of bear.
Let the currency of Zimbabwe has become so worthless.
They've retired it completely.
And the country now operates on a misks of foreign currency,
including the South Africa.
K beyond the wildlife.
There's not much to do or see.
There's rafting,
bungee jumping,
microlight flying over.
Victory,
fall fishing,
swimming.
All right,
well what the fuck did you get?
Right?
I'm not reading all this shit.
Look at this fucking videos.
Swimming and Victoria Falls.
Get the fuck Outta here.
This is this thing that looks like it's bigger than Niagara Falls.
No fucking way.
Yeah.
So basically the water isn't flowing fast enough to these fucking got,
okay,
I've got to put a,
send a link to this video.
Yeah.
Who is the absolute fucking psycho that figured out you could do that?
Dude,
if you just saw the pasty fat fucking white dude who just jumped in there.
You know what's funny?
He's there with two fucking two black guys,
man.
It'd be funny if they grabbed him and threw him over.
That was for slavery.
All right,
let me,
uh,
all right.
I got a copy of that.
Jesus Christ.
What a fucking loan.
There's no,
no way.
There's no fucking way.
No fucking way.
All right,
let's get back to the,
uh,
the things here.
All right.
Um,
where am I?
All right.
Tinder.
Oh,
Billy.
Let's read some emails for the week.
Uh,
I hooked up with this girl.
I met on Tinder the first in years.
I'm not a bad looking guy.
I think I just suck at small talk over or over text.
Any who?
This girl is 21.
I didn't expect it to go anywhere after we matched up and we ended up hooking
up.
She's really cool.
We've hung out a few times since my friend and his girlfriend started saying
that was gross.
Uh,
I am 30 years old now.
I know my friend is being lame because his girlfriend was there,
but gross not at all,
so I let them have their ignorant opinions.
Then I dropped the facts on them.
She looks more like she's 24th do this really isn't helping you.
I look like I'm 25 that's also not helping you.
She took extra classes to graduate college early and is already accepted into
medical schools.
Still not helping you.
She speaks four languages fluently.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
She's not a dumb fuck.
She knows what she's doing.
I don't mean hello and goodbye.
She can carry on full on comp conversations in Mandarin,
French and Italian as well as English.
Of course.
She has much better table manners then both of them.
Oh,
you said that.
Wow.
If you just torched the whole friendship.
I pointed this out to my friend's girlfriend.
He didn't have a Napkin on her lap and our elbows were on the table and pointed
that very fact out to her as well.
Also,
I mentioned that when me and this girl met for a drink,
she put her napkin on your lap before she bought her drink to her mouth.
Uh,
which would have hovered over her lap awareness levels maximum.
Okay.
Uh,
21.
Who gives a fuck?
I like to think I'm right and then I made a good point,
but I need the opinion of your honor.
Billy Burke.
Uh,
yes.
Fuck.
Damn.
You're 30.
She's 21.
Who gives a shit good for you.
You're fucking crushing it.
She's a fucking adult and uh,
she's not a dope.
You didn't roof here and there too.
Miserable fucks in our relationship.
All right.
We've got food coming out of the side of their mouth.
Carry on.
All right.
My kid wants to play football.
Hey,
Billy Bellacheck,
Bella,
Bella Lik,
um,
I'm a huge football fan.
Watch every week,
Yada,
Yada.
My kid is seven and loves it too.
He plays baseball and basketball and it's really fast.
We played catch with a football in the year and he's really fast,
which has given him the desire to be a wide receiver.
Granted it's not the worst pound and you can get on the field.
I don't want to play football.
Uh,
he's a great athlete,
but I'm not one of those delusional dads who thinks he's going pro in whatever
he does.
He's not small,
but definitely not the biggest of his age group.
How do I not sound like a cranky old man or worried old mother and explained to
him how it's not worth it?
Should I just show him footage from a 30 for 30 to scare the shit out of them?
Oh Man.
Dude,
that is such a,
um,
contemporary question,
relevant question,
whatever,
you know.
Um,
yeah,
I would actually defer this to the Internet.
I believe it or not.
And then you have to use your own judgment as to whether you're listening to
somebody who is informed and,
or somebody who isn't.
Can you,
can you do like a middle ground and maybe hockey?
Maybe you can get them into hockey.
I guess you,
you'd have to like hockey if you don't like hockey.
Um,
cause it would have the physical aspects of it.
But,
um,
those guys don't just go,
don't fucking slam into each other every play.
Um,
you know what,
dude,
I don't know how to bring that up.
I would just be honest with them and just say,
listen,
I don't want to seem like a cranky old man.
I don't want to seem like a worried mother like you just said.
But um,
I'm really worried about the longterm effects
of you playing football.
And I would even say longterm effects talk to them like an adult.
Just say,
yeah,
I am worried that you know,
you,
if you get hit the wrong way,
God forbid people get paralyzed,
people die.
People have fucking don't say fucking people who have brain injuries.
I would go down that road and just,
I would just say to the kid,
yeah,
your concerns.
And if he really wants to fucking play,
then you know,
you just do what Peyton did.
You just get some roids sent house.
You put them in your wife's name and you get this kid,
you,
you let them do a cycle right before the season starts and you let him kick the
fuck out of somebody else's kid,
not yours.
Right?
There you go.
Okay.
I'm just fucking around.
Obviously.
The first thing I said I would,
I would seek more information on that and figure out how you do it in the best
way.
All right.
Pete and my house man,
terrorist bill,
my house needs painting.
It has about six years.
It's been about six years since it's been painted.
We moved in four years ago.
I've painted a house before by,
my wife thinks I'm going to fuck it up and or it will take too long.
You know what?
I'm with her already.
Uh,
I've been telling her that I,
I'll say it'll save thousands of dollars.
She says that's not the point.
She's right.
It's not entirely the point.
I make good money.
I just want to paint the house.
It's my first house and I feel the need to do something to leave my mark on it,
literally and figuratively speaking.
Um,
I'll take,
it'll take me about three weeks to do the whole house.
Not working every day,
but three,
four days a week.
I have a neighbor who's going to be home from college,
who I've introduced to music and he's never heard.
Oh,
listen to him to music he's never heard.
So it's a great excuse to give the kid a few bucks while introducing him to
early Soundgarden and Jane's Addiction.
Uh,
she started bringing things up like,
well,
what if it starts raining?
She's got nothing left on this one.
I have to paint my house.
It's not a manly thing.
It's not to prove a point.
It's taking pride and ownership thoughts on this.
I say,
you listen to your wife.
Do you want to do some fucking,
you finish your garage to something like that.
Okay.
Do something in there where it's a part of a room that she doesn't have to
fucking deal with.
Just have some pros come over there and have them knock it out and have them
charge you through the fucking nose and you sit inside drinking a fucking beer.
All right?
This other shit that you can do on the house.
Um,
you know,
I just painting a fucking houses.
That's a big one,
dude.
That is a big one.
I understand that you want to do it.
MMM.
But yeah,
I,
I'm with you wife on this one too.
You know,
you already got a fucking job.
Okay.
You make a good money.
Pay Somebody to do it.
All right?
There's a bunch of shit on my house that I started to do and I just started
thinking,
you know what?
I'm making a good living.
Fuck this.
Why don't I have a pro come over.
I can do it.
I can figure I was patching up holes in walls.
I was learning how to do that shit.
You know,
I was fucking fixing the j trap under my sink and doing all of that fucking
crap.
Didn't learn all of that shit.
My last department.
Then I got to the house and it's like,
all right,
well I can do this or I can have a pro come over here and do it and do it
fucking right.
Okay.
Now I'm speaking for myself here.
My house was fucking wall toward wall floor to ceiling inside and out.
Do it yourself fucking hacks.
All right.
And
I wasn't going to carry that fucking baton anymore.
Everything that I have had done on my house has been done by fucking
professionals and my house is as much as I bitch about it.
MMM.
It's 70% this shit at this point.
It really is no ticket.
This garage done.
And then I got,
you know,
my kitchen's fucked up.
Don't you get me started with all the exterior doors and windows.
Okay.
In the wood rot and some of the other shit I have to deal with.
But generally speaking like this fucking place is solid and um,
I dunno dude.
Fuck that to you.
You won't go a fucking ladder.
You know what I mean?
Mixing the Goddamn paint,
doing all of that bullshit.
Um,
I would just,
I would,
yeah,
just,
just pay for it.
Just pay for it and just say,
this bill is what you do.
Don't just do it.
Just don't do what your wife says.
Get something out of it.
All right.
Be like,
alright.
You know what,
I thought about it.
I don't agree with it,
but I know that you would feel better if somebody else did it.
Okay?
So I am going to hire a professional company to paint the house and she's like,
okay good.
And I'll be like,
I'm not finished.
However,
because I am doing that,
I am going to Redo the garage and the garage is going to be a place where me and
my friends,
we play poker and we smoked cigars once a week.
I'm gonna have my own fridge in there.
There's going to be a lock on the door that you do not have a key for.
When you see,
um,
exotic women walking in and out of that,
you are not to ask questions.
Is this understood?
Right?
You just say crazy shit like that right over the fucking top.
And then she's done laughing.
Then you say,
what the fuck you really want?
It will pale in comparison to fucking exotic women walking in and out of your
garage and you'll be fucking in.
So I would think about what else you want.
All right?
And at the end of the fucking day,
you're going to get something that you want somebody else who's going to pay you
out.
Paint,
uh,
paint your house.
I think you're gonna win.
Personally speaking.
That's what I think.
All right.
And you know what,
that's the podcast for this week,
mother fuckers.
Um,
thank you for listening as always and I'm really excited about all these dates
that I have coming up and,
uh,
I,
I cannot fucking wait to go to Iowa.
I'm so excited about the Saint Louis.
Some of the great fucking sports fans I've ever met in my life or in Saint Louis
and God knows they got enough Budweiser's.
Long Beach is fucking,
uh,
the Goddamn motherfucking,
Richard Pryor Gig,
Riverside,
California.
I fucking,
you know,
when I was learning how to fly,
I had to,
I had the land there and I did the,
the fucking French valley flight had a flight or Riverside,
then out the French valley and back to Long Beach.
Um,
shit,
I might fly over there.
That would be awesome.
Um,
ames,
Iowa obviously cannot wait to go to there or Lando.
I haven't been there in a minute.
Jacksonville,
Florida.
Last time I was there and went to a gun gun range and shut fucking guns with
silencers.
You think I'm not gonna do that again?
Portland may my old stomping grounds.
Albany,
New York,
um,
Newark,
New Jersey.
These are all places I love all those places.
I can't wait to get out there.
I've been working my ass off of my act.
If he come out,
I'm gonna make you laugh your fucking ass off.
Okay.
So if you can make it,
I would really appreciate it.
All right.
And I'm actually trying to think of a tour name if you can come up with a name
for it,
you know,
cause these dates.
I'm in Canada,
I'm in North America.
I'm in fucking,
you know,
well Canada's North America.
I'm in the United States of America,
right?
I'm on the East Coast,
I'm in the Midwest,
I'm in the south.
I can't think of a name for the tour.
I don't know why I have to name the tour,
but my agent says I got to come up with a name for it.
So I'm thinking the checking in on your tour.
I don't know why.
If you guys got any ideas,
just tweet them to me,
uh,
at Bill Burr,
whatever the,
I don't even know what my Twitter is,
you know,
I don't even know what it is.
So whatever.
If you've got time to look it up,
send it to me.
If you don't,
I understand.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
We'll talk to you on Thursday.